ok let's get into audience questions
this week and there are some good ones
many of you probably saw the letter
published in Harper's Magazine signed by
more than a hundred and fifty people
criticizing a callout culture and
canceled culture as it has become known
to many and I got a bunch of questions
essentially saying can we cancel or ban
cancel culture maybe by making political
beliefs a protected class much like
nationality or religion etc I mean
listen I I think that that's very very
dangerous to do and there's a couple
different reasons why if you look at
religious beliefs being considered a
protected class that's already
problematic now I understand the basis
for you know if if you need to establish
in all aspects of the law non
discrimination on the basis of religion
or lack of religion then it follows that
you probably have to include religious
beliefs as a protected class but
understand that religious beliefs are
self professed in other words they're
not immutable saying that you can't
discriminate on the basis of race or
national origin as examples or
disability one has no control over those
characteristics whereas you very much
have control over your religious beliefs
and of course there's the reality that
you know people are born into religion
in many ways but it is different but the
point is to add something like political
belief as a protected class would create
absolute and complete chaos white
supremacy as a value set would be
protected business can't fire someone or
say they won't serve a customer who
comes in wearing a KKK hood because
those are political beliefs and if you
make political beliefs protected under
the law all of a sudden you are forced
to do business with individuals in these
categories and the reality is that it's
BS in the sense that it runs directly
counter to everything that Republicans
claim to walk it
runs directly counter to the idea of
small-government wait a second
you think many of them think that
non-discrimination laws are already too
strict but they want to add political
beliefs to that list many of them
believe that businesses are already over
regulated you want to add another
element where businesses are not free to
decide how they're going to operate
their businesses it is a disastrous idea
and at its core I mean listen we can
have a reasonable debate and I'm glad to
engage in it about what our productive
and unproductive examples of boycotting
or calling for boycotts that's a great
conversation to have and there's no one
answer to it and sometimes a boycott or
a call for a cancellation makes sense
and sometimes it doesn't let's figure
that out but the people who are talking
about ban the epidemic of cancel call
culture they don't like that speech has
consequences and that there are new
tools for people to voice their
displeasure like for example social
media there's really no way to end
cancel culture without curtailing speech
rights something being a right the right
to speak doesn't mean that it must be
free of ramifications and the
consequences to speech are speech in and
of themselves so no political ideology
should not be a protected class in fact
it might make the problem worse imagine
imagine an employee says something
absolutely insane and horrifying and a
company can't fire them because it's
their legally protected political belief
now the company has to keep an employee
on who regularly makes anti-semitic or
racist comments they can't fire them
because those are merely political
beliefs this is literally the free
market we're talking about here right
businesses are driven by customer wants
and desires if one customer says I don't
want to do business with you if you have
a white supremacist maybe you ignore it
if you have a white supremacist working
for you 400,000 people say it then maybe
you evaluate that in the market
and decide I'd better get rid of this
employee of course assuming that there's
not a contract that keeps the employee
in place or if it does you have to look
at whether the contract has any kind of
clause in it about unbecoming behavior
right we have a system for this stuff
and simply saying political beliefs are
protected as if they were race or
national origin or disability not a good
idea and I would be against it